these people want to understand the
crimes of the past they're traveling to
the former death camp Auschwitz Birkenau
dr. Leon vane Tom wanted his wife Eva
Maria to accompany him the 89 year old
is an Auschwitz survivor vain hope who
was born in Poland emphasizes he's here
voluntarily today that's important to
him the group includes young and old
Germans Ukrainians and Russians they've
come for the 70th anniversary of the
liberation of Auschwitz
and they've come to here Leon mind hub
and other survivors of the camp talk
those were the wooden barracks over
there and that's where I was I must have
inner block number 10 because I could
always see the women's camp to the right
how does his wife feel about being here
yeah oh it's very disturbing sad has
what happened to her husband influenced
her life as well
probably indirectly though not
consciously she's a good soul and it's
to her credit that she's put up with me
for more than 40 years it was no
sacrifice name I hope not
the vine tubs are here for the second
time they've come back together to share
with younger generations Wadley on vine
table endured to make sure it's not
forgotten the group of companies leon
vine table two places closely associated
with the horrors of the holocaust in the
former women and children's barracks and
auschwitz birkenau the on vine table
briefly steps away from the group does
this place also evoke memories i have to
think about my sisters they were
probably interned here the hair was
shaved off its scarves on their heads
it's unfathomable really possible it so
vividly entered in my mind even though
it's 70 years ago can't be erased
lay on Vine Cubs two sisters also
survived Auschwitz and the Holocaust
his mother Nadia wine table was gassed
by the SS on her arrival at the death
camp so was his aunt Eva all the on vine
cob has from his mother is a single
photograph and the memory of their life
together until he was 17 and came to
this place
it's cold today
despite warm shoes thick jackets and
warm hats me on vine table patiently
answers everyone's questions
my first impression I was clutching my
rucksack
and this man in a striped prisoner's
uniform tore it out of my hands and I
said I have my postage stamps in there
nobody comes here to live what is he
talking about and then came the painful
realization this was not a place for
life oh not with its electrified fence
with wires running along so people
weren't meant to survive here
his young listeners want to document and
pass on his memories but it's not easy
for them to remain passive observers
they go back to their lodgings to
process their experience of Auschwitz
one of them Tina was surprised by her
own reaction when we were in Birkenau
and Auschwitz I felt like I was in a
bubble I thought I'd feel sad and become
very emotional that happened in some
situations but often I was puzzled that
nothing came that I just stood there
feeling empty Holocaust survivors and
this group of young people spent a week
together in Auschwitz they talked
together in small groups for instance
with yunsik Tilly neeraj he was only a
few years younger than his listeners
when he was sent to the camp the number
of survivors who can tell their stories
is dwindling but many people want to
hear them like Filip Tom who's studying
journalism
why do somehow whatever it's meant in
German history what its effect was on
post-war German society that there's a
consensus that outfits should never
happen again but I wanted to know what
it was like for those people who were
there what they experienced how they
felt and now they live with having been
part of it that's why I'm here that's
what I've learned
lay on vine table has brought something
special with him a few photos and
documents that remain from his past
that's my ghetto workers ID from
September 1943 I was 17 you were so
handsome
not exactly handsome but special for
both the survivors and the group the
deluge of tragic fates impressions and
images is deeply moving there struggling
together to make sure none of this is
forgotten and that's why Eva Maria vine
table accompanies her husband on his
mission which is still unfinished demons
when you look at the situation in Europe
where unfortunately there's a political
move to the right and certain countries
it's important for him that people
protest against it each in our own way
the younger people here are also
interested in the perpetrators how it
began and the connection to the current
racist pegida protests in Germany
they happen can't move it but is it we
just had a debate about them because I
said the people who did this must have
been sick monsters and my colleagues
said no they were ordinary people that's
what's so bad ordinary people who
murdered Jews and then listen to bomb I
think that's happening now - with the
whole pegida movement they're targeting
the middle classes again ordinary people
you know he gives me the shivers just to
think about it begins a heartless no
internet funding
Leon vine table returns to the death
camp for one more interview overnight a
thick blanket of snow has settled over
the countryside the color on the ground
merges seamlessly into the sky before
the group leaves Leon vine table agrees
to answer a few more questions
what does this place represent yes
extreme the most extreme limits of the
imagination show noted or asserted in
English they expected the worst but not
the unthinkable you haven't it's truly
unique in the history of the world that
is the I'm a legend in the best position
whatever forgotten
it would raise the possibility that
something like this could happen again
then giving its memory alive as a way of
ensuring that it can't occur again we're
getting it I guess the worst thing we
could do
you